in the last video we gave a basic
outline of the different scenarios that
might play out in 2013 or at least the
different budgetary proposals on the
table from the administration from the
republicans and what will happen if they
don't come into agreement which was the
fiscal cliff which is this
fairly unusual situation where the both
parties to the negotiation set up this
thing that will automatically happen at
the beginning of 2013 that it would be
painful for both parties and the
thinking being that it'll force them to
come maybe to some type of an agreement
sooner than later the fiscal cliff is
what neither the republicans or the
administration want because it raises
taxes which the republicans don't want
and it reduces spending which the
president doesn't want and the the core
arguments we touched it on the last
video we'll go into more depth in this
one is
just as we are beginning to recover from
our last recession it might not be
useful for our economy to try to suck
out half a trillion dollars so let's
think about the different the different
issues at play
so right over here because i have some
charts most of these are from the
congressional budget office and there's
a bunch of assumptions that go into this
and there are many people who will
debate the assumptions that they make
but they at least directionally
directionally show the right things
so this right over here this first chart
is compares deficits or surpluses and
really ever since the early 2000s we've
been running deficits and all and as we
got into the the late i guess
tens or you know 2008 2010 time frame
2009 time frame as we went into a
financial crisis when you go to fight
when the economy contracts you get hit
in two ways when you think about deficit
spending on one end you bring in less
revenues the economy is shrinking and on
the other end you have to spend more you
have to give people more benefits more
unemployment benefits things like that
so when you whenever you see the economy
shrink you will see naturally
all else all other things being equal
you will see deficits increase and
that's what you saw right over here and
on top of that the government is trying
to bail things out is putting doing
stimulus spending and all that in order
to minimize the effect of the deficit
and that's why you see here in 2008 2009
we start running significant significant
deficits now what's interesting what's
interesting is what's going to happen
going forward and going forward there's
two of these scenarios right here there
is the cbo's baseline projection and
then there's the alternative fiscal
scenario and just to be clear where we
are we are entering this phase right
over here in
2013
and the baseline projection is
essentially if the government takes no
more action and if the government takes
no more action then the fiscal cliff
will be triggered we will essentially
have 500 billion less in in 2013's
deficit and so what you see here is that
the deficits go down dramatically
go down
go down dramatically we start we we have
to borrow less on an annual basis now
the alternative fiscal scenario is if
the as if we essentially continue if we
extend our existing spending
and if we continue to extend the bush
era tax cuts we go along this path and
so if you care a lot about deficits the
fiscal cliff scenario which is this top
line this is actually the fiscal let me
write that in a color you can see
that's actually the fiscal cliff the
fiscal cliff scenario actually looks
pretty good hey look we have much much
lower deficits in that scenario than if
we were to continue
if we were to continue the tax cuts and
if we were to continue the spending so
there that looks like like actually an
argument for the fiscal cliff
now let's look at this now this is we're
going to talk about the aggregate debt
when we say deficit we're talking about
the shortfall in a given year the debt
is the aggregate amount that the
government owes so this is federal debt
held by the public historically and as
projected in cbo's baseline and a lot of
what cbo when they project they can only
do so much in in projecting how good the
economy might be or how bad it might be
to a large degree they extrapolate from
where we are right now
and right over here you see debt as a
percentage of gdp so you can imagine
during world war ii we had a lot of debt
as a percentage of gdp see over here is
at the after after the end of world war
ii we start crossing over a hundred
percent of gdp is our debt the aggregate
amount that the government owns and then
it owes and then it delivered and then
you see this this rough trend roughly
from the early 80s all early 80s until
now where we'd have we've had increasing
increasing aggregate debt there was
there were some moments in the late 90s
early 2000s where we took it down very
very very strong economy we started
running surpluses we started to pay down
some of our debt but then we kind of hit
back on this debt increasing trend line
and once again
if we continue in the alternative fiscal
scenario which is really continuing to
do what we do today which is extend the
tax cuts and continue to have roughly
the same level of spending you see that
the debt only continues to increase
only continues to increase in the
baseline projection this is actually the
fiscal cliff scenario this is where no
new legislation is passed those triggers
which in which the bush era tax cuts
expire and the the the spending cuts
that are triggered by the fiscal cliff
scenario hit we run lower deficits and
we actually see that debt as a
percentage of gdp actually starts to go
down which is a at least from a balance
sheet perspective seems like a good
thing so these first two charts say hey
really maybe this fiscal cliff thing
isn't so bad it will actually
significantly lower the
deficit on an annual basis and as a
percentage of gdp we will as a country
delever
now let's think about the arguments why
well maybe we don't want to be that
aggressive when it comes to
reducing our deficit or reducing our
debt as a percentage of gdp
this first chart right over here is
is the
we'll read it right over here it's the
percent of our population that is
employed
and you see right here so it's a proxy
for employment or unemployment or in
this case it's employment and you see we
hit a major recession at the end of end
of 2008 you saw the percentage of our
population that is employed go down
dramatically we kind of hit bottom over
here and we're having a kind of a shaky
hopefully a shaky recovery right now
it's not even clear how how good that
will be but hopefully we're having a
shaky recovery of sorts and so just as
we're starting to recover it might not
be helpful to take essentially
500 billion dollars out of the economy
in order to pay down debt so the fiscal
cliff scenario might make us go back
into
a little bit a little bit of a lurch and
most of most economists are predicting
about on the order of a percent slower
growth if the fiscal cliff scenario were
to hit
actually
most economists not not a percent
they're actually expecting about a two
percent hit to the economy if the fiscal
cliff scenario would happen and rather
from going from 1.7 percent growth we
might go to
negative a slight recession slight
slight receding of the economy so that
could be that's obviously not a good
scenario that we want to be in
the other chart that i have right over
here these are yields on 10-year
treasury notes this seems like a very
technical thing to talk about but this
is essentially the interest one way to
think about is the interest that the
government is paying when it borrows
money for 10 years
and one of the main arguments for paying
down for paying down debt is that if the
government keeps borrowing money it's
going to crowd out other borrowers it's
going to make demand for money high and
maybe the supply will be more and more
scarce and interest rates will go up so
a lot of borrowing could make interest
rates go up and then the other idea is
well if there's a lot of just borrowing
and spending going on
and if we don't have a lot of productive
capacity it could also lead to inflation
or maybe when the government has a huge
debt
there they have an incentive to try to
have inflationary policies so that in
real terms that debt seems to be less
but when you look at the debt markets
and these are these are market-driven
numbers the federal reserve does not
control 10-year yields the federal
reserve controls controls short-term
yields
you see that we have historically low
interest rates so the bond market
the bond market and there's some very
smart people who are living or who make
their living investing in the bond
markets one of the biggest markets if
not the biggest um is saying it's really
not worried about deficits it has it's
willing to lend to the u.s government at
all time low interest rates
it's not expecting any inflation if
anything the bond market is saying that
the biggest risk in the economy is
continued sluggish growth the biggest
risk in the economy is maybe even some
some form of deflation so this this
super low bond yields right over here
would be an argument that well yeah if
you believe what the mod market is
saying we one definitely should not suck
money out of the economy and the risks
of maintaining
high levels of debt might not be as high
as some people are saying that you're
not going to see interest rates and
inflation go through the roof tomorrow
now if you
if you ascribe to that second point of
view that okay yes we should be
responsible we should start to lo at
minimum lower our deficit and over time
as a percentage of gdp
lower our debt
the other question is how do you do that
the republicans would want to do it
mainly through spending cuts while the
democrats would want to do that
possib possibly through spending cuts
but also by maintaining some of the tax
or letting some of the tax cuts on the
wealthy expire and maybe even adding
some other tax and so these two charts
inform some of those positions and i'm
trying to
give as balance of an approach as i can
so for a democrat they might look at
this chart right over here and they
might say well look average tax rates
for the highest income taxpayers if you
look at it on a historical basis it
looks like it's relatively low it looks
like it's relatively low and a lot of
this comes out of the the idea that even
though the marginal tax rates are higher
than what you see here
high high income taxpayers a lot of
their income might be from capital gains
from dividends those are taxed at 15
they also might have a more
sophisticated accountants who can get
the more deductions and so that's why
you have them paying and they're getting
more sophisticated as time goes by and
that's why you see this trend this trend
going down and so this could be an
argument uh well at least relative to
historical basis that this this category
of folks might be able to afford to pay
more there's also another argument in
terms of kind of a stimulus argument or
how to minimize impact on the economy
that if you were to give
if you were to give so if you have a
dollar that you want to somehow
stimulate
the economy with
well one the government could spend the
money and there are many arguments very
good arguments why the government is not
always the most efficient spender of
money and not always spending it in the
best way but they will definitely spend
it so you give it to the government you
give it to the government they'll
definitely spend it and then some so
they'll definitely spend that dollar at
least it will enter into the economy
now if you give it to
the middle class if you give it to the
middle class they are also likely to
spend it or to spend a good chunk of it
maybe save a little bit and the argument
would be that if you give it to someone
who's affluent
if you give it to someone affluent
they are likely to save it
now saving is not always a bad thing
if you are if you are low on investment
you need more savers if interest rates
if interest rates were going through the
roof right over here that means that we
need we don't have enough supply of
money in which case it would make sense
that we would try to incent savers so if
you have a situation of in the late 70s
where you have inflation going through
the roof you want people to actually
invest more you want a higher supply of
money makes complete sense to
put more money in the hands of people
who are likely to save and invest that
money but here at least if you believe
the bond market it looks like we have a
demand problem that it's actually it's
very cheap to get capital if anything
there's a surplus of capital out there
but there's not enough demand in order
for people to
i guess get the get the the economy to
run at its potential
so a democratic argument would be look
if we're gonna if we're gonna if we're
gonna
have this dollar the person that we're
best off giving it to
is the middle class or possibly to some
degree the government because at least
they will spend it it will help
stimulate the economy here it will go
into savings but that doesn't seem like
what what the government's right now
now the counter argument that you might
get from someone at the right is that
first the government is just a hugely
inefficient spender of capital and
there's a lot of evidence to you
definitely need a government but they
don't always spend money in the most
efficient and even sometimes it leads to
levels of corruption
and oftentimes when you do something in
the name of stimulus which maybe maybe
it might make sense to do it in the
short term but once that program is in
place it's very hard to remove that
program people start to depend on it
even when you when in theory you don't
need the stimulus anymore it's very hard
to shrink the size of government
and so and there's some argument for
that if you look at if you look at
outlays government expenditures as a
percentage of gdp it does look like on a
historic basis it is high
now
to some degree this is due because to
the fact that we have entered into kind
of a major recessionary phase you see
that in all of the major recessions in
all the major recessions the government
gets less revenue
so the government gets less revenue and
has to do more outlays this happens in
every this happens well i would say in
most in most recessions and this
happened in dramatic form
where we started to have more outlays we
had actually at this point we had wars
that we were funding and we were doing
these trillion dollar
stimulus packages and we had these
trillion dollar bailouts at the same
time that the economy was the economy
was receding right over here but just
when you look at this it does look like
the government spending as a percentage
of gdp is at historical highs and as we
say as you know the argument would have
it it's very hard to get that to shrink
even when it should be shrinking and
it's often being it's often being
deployed in less than efficient ways
so i will leave you there my intent
really is not to sway you one way or the
other but to really just hope that you
have good information when you think
about the issues surrounding the fiscal
cliff